hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 16 video
agents of shocking twists a couple big
reveals and actually one of my big
predictions came true so I'm really
happy they showed us a little bit of
mercy and didn't wait to like next week
to explain the big WTF just to explain
Luke Mitchell you may remember him from
The Tomorrow People he played a
super-powered person on that show now
he's playing an inhuman so it's just
like a nice easy transition he's not
playing a comic book character he's an
original creation of the show but he's
basically like magneto Lite for all
intents and purposes it looks like his
power is the ability to manipulate
electromagnetism
although the way he explained it it
might be just a little bit different
from the way magneto manipulates the
Earth's magnetic field
it's just twisting things just a little
bit just to avoid any major lawsuits but
lots awesome stuff to get through let's
start with top five moments careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet
number five meet Lincoln Magneto jr.
he's kind of our intro into the world of
the Inhumans in like this mountain
Chinese place the name that they gave it
as Chinese so so let's just assume that
it's in China because that's where
Skye's mother was killed or you know so
he thought when he said that Gordon is
the only way in or out I think he just
said they do whatever they can to keep
it off of maps it's like a light version
of ATS LAN and as he explained it the
society there is relatively similar to
like in at LAN there are in humans that
have not taken in the Terrigen mists so
they they look just like normal people I
like the way he made it seem like a day
spa like an Inhumans day spa go get some
acupuncture check out the electrically
heated pool later movie nights number
four Skye jumped the line big time I
like the way they explained Skye's
transition versus the way they normally
do things only one person every couple
years gets picked to take in the mists
so they do have more diviners we don't
know how many it sounds like the reason
for not transitioning everyone not
allowing everyone to taken the Miss is
just practical like they don't have
enough diviners for every single person
in the world it does sound like you can
transform more than one person with a
diviner because Raina and Skye both took
in the mists and changed even though
Raina thinks that Skye stole something
from her like stole her gift I think I
explained in a previous video but
technically that's not true the effects
of the Terrigen mists are just based on
your genetics the way they explained is
pretty simple like it just jumps you
forward thousands of years worth of
bevel
moving out to number three though
welcome back Deathlok it's been so long
since we've seen him I am I almost
forgot about him I kind of written him
off because J August Richards had been
cast on another TV show so he just not
nearly as available as he was in season
one he's got some upgrades as Coulson
explained it like some tech upgrades and
he's been tracking down the last head of
Hydra or the last head as we know it
because Baron von Strucker is still
alive and technically he's a head of
Hydra too so they were a little
timey-wimey with the explanation there
they did tie it a little bit to age of
ultron because Hydra is experimenting on
superpower people not quite in the same
way that Baron von strucker's doing it
he's like way above and beyond what
normal hydras doing but it's just kind
of leading into what's gonna be
happening in age of Ultron the
difference is is that Baron von Strucker
is using the mind gem to experiment on
people on to number two
Fitz versus Simmons Civil War based on
that last scene with the sandwich it
seems like Fitz and Simmons were working
with each other to get the toolbox away
from the real shield the actors did an
amazing job
I totally believed that they hated each
other just because that's been status
quo for the last several episodes
he probably swapped it whenever he
picked it up who knew he was such a good
thief my guess is is that he'll meet up
with Coulson eventually Coulson hunter
and Deathlok may seem like she was gonna
stay like they they had a nice
juxtaposition with like Fitz leaving and
then make aynd of being in question it
seems like she's gonna stay but she'll
still inform for Coulson she'll still be
loyal to Coulson speaking of which
there's a nice little teaser for her
like whenever she got her nickname the
cavalry apparently based on what
Gonzales said she took down or killed a
super-powered person that had just gone
nuts we'll totally find out about that
next week so just open up it like a tab
in chrome for that and finally my number
one WTF moment Skye's mother is still
alive whenever Dee chinlock men first
walked into the room it was like stopped
she broke up Skye going after Raina I
couldn't tell like you couldn't see the
scars on her face quite as well so I was
like maybe this is a double maybe this
is like some other daughter that she has
I was just waiting to see like what the
explanation was going to be or if there
was gonna be one at all they didn't make
us wait long
it wasn't till she hugged Calvin zabo
Skye's father and said our daughter is
alive it's Daisy that I was like okay
yeah this is definitely the same person
she also had a really nice close-up so
you could see the scars from Whitehall's
operation on her I'm just gonna go ahead
and assume that agents of shield isn't
gonna like take this back from us it's
really Skye's mother
I think the explanation based on that is
that her healing factor is powerful
enough to regenerate pretty much
everything just because Whitehall
grafted a lot of her internal organs
like her blood everything on to himself
I'm wondering if all those abilities
transition to him like if he'll come
back in some altered way or if he'll be
diminished in some capacity I think this
is a sign that he will come back though
that's actually my big question for you
guys let me know in the comments do you
think you know if Skye's mother came
back because of her regeneration
abilities do you think that Whitehall is
also going to come back as like the big
bad of the season what I'm hoping is is
that he'll undergo terrigenesis
and like turn into some crazy-looking
monster in the comics this character is
known as Kraken like is the special
armor that looks like a Kraken so it
would just be really fun to see him look
like that based on his transformation
like if you think Raina looks messed up
imagine something way worse than that
overall it was a great episode it was
like very heavy on the intrigue like
Civil War Winter Soldier type stuff but
there are a couple Easter eggs that I
saw you know in addition like the Hulk
house whenever Coulson uses the hologram
with hunter here it's actually something
from one of the comics recently for the
life of me I can't remember which but
Hank McCoy is trying to evade old Steve
Rogers I think it was either from
original sin or x-men access it was
weren't from one of the big event comics
he's playing chess with someone else and
it ends up being holograms and he uses
it to trick old Steve Rogers and get
away that's what I love about Coulson so
much he's just so casual about
everything like it's no big deal so
nonchalant I think the only time we've
seen him freak out in a big way is when
his brain was getting messed with I know
when Gonzalez likes lid that World War 2
gun over to me everyone was probably
wondering if Gonzalez his father was
like a howling commando it's totally
possible killed over a hundred Nazis if
you guys saw any other Easter eggs in
the episode that I did mention just
write them below in the comments
definitely you can definitely see
they're trying to like lead into a Civil
War cuz it's like hey we're not the bad
guys we're trying to do the right thing
speaking of the movies there's actually
like a Marvel movie marathon happening
in two weeks it's like next Tuesday next
Monday and Tuesday they're gonna show
like all 11 Marvel films I'll be going
they're gonna show age of Ultron so what
I'll do is is I'll do like a
non-spoilery review so be sure to
subscribe to get that and then whenever
the movie does come out everyone has a
chance to see it I'll post like my
spoilery review there's been a lot of
talk about there being no post credits
scenes I might do like a separate video
of like my favorite post card
it seems and to talk about a little bit
more there but just to explain there are
still separate scenes at the end of the
movie that will set up the other phase
three films like Thor three Captain
America Civil War it's just that they're
not after the credits post credits means
it's like all the credits roll and then
there's the scene like shwarma so there
won't be any schwarmann type scene but
they're still gonna be like fun scenes
at the end so that's what everyone meant
this morning when they were talking
about no post credits in age of Ultron
so don't worry they're still like fun
stuff at the end of the movie well you
guys wait for that post credits video
you can click here for all my Marvel
movie videos and you can click here for
all my agents of shield videos thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you